so final fantasy news there's a delay
but but new footage keeps on coming as
well Alexa and Peter you guys watched
like almost like an hour of extra
footage 50 minutes so what exactly is
this it's like the first couple hours of
the game from what I understand they
they cut around it so like you're not
wandering around it'll cut from area to
area so you don't include the traversal
and it's like this it's the opening of
the game which is really weird yeah oh
really they just straight up show like
CG and everything yeah and so it's very
strange and I've not really seen many
people talk about it online which is
even more the only shop do their all
into something cuz the beginning shows
this scene with like the mic a character
with a beard and you're like he kind of
sounds like Noctis like the lead
character like but no I can't be him and
like a few a few moments go by within
the scene and you realize like no way
this is like 10 years in the future
they're all older like they're all
grizzled adventurers noctis has a
full-on beer yeah an Ignis looks like
Adam Jensen with like laughs yeah like
there's all this and I I mean truth be
told I actually really like the way that
they look I kind of wish those are the
default character it's really awesome a
little glad he has a ponytail yeah and
so let me yeah it shows like this scene
that's taking place like way far in the
future and then sort of fades to black
and it opens the game proper hey
remember when we drove that car is on
right well not quite that but but you
know it yeah it's alluding to what's
going to come so that was really
shocking because we'd not seen anything
like that before right and we were both
talking and how cool that be if towards
the end of the game you've actually aged
and like right on through different
things today eluates adopt being
gameplay at any stage oh no I mean there
was they were in combat but it it was it
was cut in engine I can say that all
right it look like that was kind of
engine um interesting the only final
fantasy game i can remember that plays
with the progression of time like that
is final fantasy tactics bang oh he did
it I did it already got it in he always
yeah but so like she was saying it shows
like a big chunk from the beginning of
the game and we see a lot of the places
we've seen before you know like what's
that open wilderness called the desk I
region that near
and you know hammerheads the garage well
that'll desert region know yet member we
like the disc idemo like this guy region
so like they show a lot of that they
show the garage again they show some
chocobo racing one of the things I
really liked is they show battles in a
cave like at night and if you've seen
the footage of this game before animals
in the wilderness are like more fiendish
like they're they're kind of crazy or
looking and there's a scene where he's
fighting this tall like ghastly like
samurai demon yeah and it has this tone
to it that just seems like so awesome
and and and so interesting compared to
the light-hearted fashion show that is
most of the name otherwise also i may be
wrong at this is speaking is like a
final fantasy outsider but both things
you just mentioned sound like they would
have been really good to show at like at
e3 press conference maybe they the stuff
they showed it III was a joke they
really shouldn't have shown any of that
stuff like the boss fight didn't work
the VR stuff was not interesting right
so many of the things they showed in
here would have got people talking and
they kind of missed their boat they
missed the stage the delay i think has
taken over the conversation presently
right yeah cuz that's good that is good
footage like so for months we've been
teeth they've teased us about syd who's
a recurring final fantasy character he's
in every final fantasy and he's in this
footage like five minutes in we like
walks in he's like this like this
grizzled old mechanic is going that
context for this what do they like how
did they set this footage up is there
like somebody saying hey here's an hour
of the game it's just a game played yeah
it gives some steaming gamescom is going
on okay they've got that demo so these
are press assets no no no I mean it's on
YouTube but essentially yeah it is just
like a dump just like here's a here's
some footage not so and it's like and it
shows like buying food at diners taking
on hunts fishing cooking camping side
quests it shows how you can do like
double attacks like team up attacks with
other guys on the team where you like
temporary control them right and it has
deeper combat Mathis is this period it
shows the map it shows it shows it shows
the progression in the skill tree and it
shows it shows a bunch of other
characters we've only seen in concept
art and it introduces the conflict
that's set up in Kings glaive and and
and it's just so big and there's so much
in it and I'm so sad that nobody is
talking about it because
are all talking about the delay back
back to the fashion thing that can
actually heated almost way I really want
to bring that up again because it's so
ridiculous to me like you change your
clothes in it this isn't like uh this is
a fantasy based on reality right so what
that means is this is a game with a lot
of modern touches and so I you know as
you change your armor it's reflected on
your character like that you see in the
world as you're running around and they
show knocked us in a bunch of different
outfits and the rest of his gang and
it's like they went to gap the boy you
saw how he's got a baseball hat really
yeah he bought the puffy vest like I
can't do that why are you what the yeah
if you're if you're gonna show me a
character that's like dressed in a big
black leather coat with a bunch of
zipper okay fine do that appears I don't
tap into like the mall of america
shopping tour you know in your game
likes work they're probably getting some
money from that what was that final
fantasy 13 yeah the prada rags or
whatever louisvuitton it was that's
great for square enix but who the hell
cares on the fans side how to make that
cheddar 15 is amelie and I wear a golden
state warriors jersey in this game wait
for the deal see there's like a lot like
415 they're doing a lot of like real
world stuff like they were saying that
there's like God what's name of the
camping equipment brand Coleman Coleman
in the film there are signs in the
background for uniqlo cup noodle and
beets what's in the film there's a big
sign for beats that you walk by anyway
it's gross what is going on so gross
it's crap out of my game they're trying
they're trying to ground it in reality
and I understand that but like I don't
know like one of those guys is like
super cute and you can put me in like
white jeans and it's like can I get like
one for me in North Face like
snowboarding Jack yeah I'm sure I'm sure
that that's possible ah as a it's great
to me I love this as a red-blooded
female that enjoys dress-up and cute
boys I'm okay with electricity giveaways
to but that doesn't mean
final fantasy the kingdom is at stake
things are falling apart around you but
make sure you get that crisp white man
yeah I want to wear that bubble Jack and
I want to watch some [ __ ] chickens
race each other yeah this of our dreams
yeah what else was in the gameplay at
managing we know Sammy car though that's
it change the colors your chocobo can
you really even how you can be like pain
die die die you collect stuff in the
environment you can die the color of
your choke Oh dip it in oh wait that
brings you to another thing remember
final fantasy eight the junction ting
system where you had to draw power out
yeah you you do that is 15 now so you
you can is what it looks like it's like
you're drawing magic from a stone in the
world which is sort of like this
temporary ownership over abilities where
you don't actually like learn these
skills right have them what's the chance
just fake it City what is Chad saying
you looked at the champions are babble
excesses if you are not on fleek you
cannot save the country oh that's me oh
oh there is a line what does he say
they're fighting and he turns one of the
guys turns to him and says stop bitching
and start killing yeah it's like look at
this chocobos okay um I don't know okay
this is ridiculous well there you go
Final Fantasy 15 this is our PSA in case
you didn't know square enix but add a
shedload of footage today according to
our to Final Fantasy 15 X first it's
quite a quite a whirlwind big dump I go
check it out which YouTube's it on is
it's a square is the one YouTube we all
know it's not dailymotion um I think
it's on like the fun it's not like the
square enix account and it's only in
English it's only out in English it
doesn't have like a weird like like
Japanese title or anything the master
version of the game is done in English
no I mean like the actual video itself I
give your search for it it has many
stairs channel go to the top of the feed
yeah okay yeah there you go check it out
after the show thanks so much I'll x-ray
Korea praetor burn and interesting I
said you're relatively complicated name
and I [ __ ] up on Oh father I
appreciate it all three syllables are my
whole life people pronouncing my name
correctly that's one
I want somebody to screw it up okay
welcome to my world Peter yeah thank you
both so much for coming talk